okay for people joining this live stream
uh we are going to be talking about uh
the question of how one represents
formal theories
in orphan language
so for people let's see do we have
actually
is andre here yet um
he's not but he's on his way okay oh boy
maybe i should
i'm gonna have to give the introduction
twice but but okay so it goes
all right so the issue is
uh what's a good example here ring for
example okay so
in axiomatic theory we have
oh andre just arrived okay great okay
so we're talking about representation of
formal operators emotion language
okay so normally when we have you know
a plus or an f or whatever else we sort
of know what it means
but we have this notion of formal
operators that we use for theorem
proving and so on
where we don't want to say what that
plus is
it's we're representing a circle plus
here but
we just want it to be a formal plus just
like the
a's the a here is a formal a and we
invented this mechanism a few years ago
of these dotted formal
characters right which represent which
which are
set up i don't think you can assign
values to them i think that's
yeah that why am i getting this thing
going to how do i set this not to go to
the messages window
i don't know how it set itself to go to
the messages window how do i unset that
john is the expert yeah um
the the it's probably in the preferences
yeah i think it is yeah and i think it's
also a bug that it caused me to have
that it caused that it went
this has happened on your system there's
been a historical times
a long time and we've never figured out
well it unless it has to do with some of
the apps that we
you know perhaps i'm sure it does but
still it would be good to know like
which one's doing it and we haven't even
figured that out right
and i'm sure that it it's happened in
the last day to me
right now i mean in fact probably can i
bring back the messages window to just
close it and it's now dead and then you
can get it back from the windows
right but is it still going to have its
content in or is it going to be yes it
will
okay then i think i can tell you oh
look at this look at this look at this
i wonder whether this has to do with the
parallel kernel stuff
um so
steven to fix it option inspector
okay i'm just going to give you a i'm
going to make
for qa i'm going to make a copy of this
um okay
let's just window
i have a suspicion actually that had to
do with a presentation i did yesterday
and i was given a notebook for it um
let me just send that out
is there somebody playing brady's p.m
here i'm going to just get here
okay
okay sorry tell me what to do on that
option inspector
options picture okay uh
okay uh global uh
you're looking for message options you
can just type it in
uh those first four warning error
console kernel
just uh click the x's next to them all
on the left
click the x's to make them go away
the warning the warning one isn't just a
beep
uh if you click the x's it just sets it
to default
which actually i guess the yeah
i mean to console
kernel message accent says print to
console
it certainly shouldn't
that
that default went bad yes
and um i suspect that
somebody's modified something to change
the apparent defaults i mean you can do
that
um by all right well so that may be the
problem okay so let's
record that fact and let's go on with
that meeting if
wouldn't it be said at the notebook
level you could have looked at it at
that scope right
but but we want to change the behavior
so it's fixed for all of his notebooks
you know what this this is still doing
this this is still doing it
it just it just it it just didn't
send the message to the right place
it just did the exact same thing
so check that preference at the notebook
scope
um let's just see what's going on or for
the front end
at the notebook scope okay so what about
this front end
but that's what global is print to
notebook it says right there kernel
message action print to notebook
uh oh it remove the beep sorry sorry
make it just print a notebook i think
that's a
that's a bug uh in the front end which
we've just never gotten around to fixing
nope still happens it's beeping
it's the kernel message action this is a
kernel message right
uh yeah
yeah um
um i wonder if somebody
i mean i i don't want to spend a lot of
time debugging this but
i i i can imagine possibilities of ways
that it might
have been you know torqued by something
but
i i don't want to spend a lot of time on
this right now
right fine but if we can somebody can
work with roger
yes yes so in my front end there's no
list around it it's just the string but
but that
that shouldn't make a difference the
beep thing i i
i remember a bug about that but that
should not make a difference
um it doesn't make a difference to the
same thing yeah
so did somebody modify it at that dollar
front-end session level
yeah that that's a possibility but i i
feel like we spent enough time on this
already okay
well should i just restart the front end
um i doubt that it will make a
difference
okay i really need i mean this bug needs
to get fixed but okay
no matter let's let's just go back to
the meeting um
uh let's see
um
okay onward um
so all right so introduction to this
the goal is to represent an expression
like this
formally okay the variables
are even more formal than our usual
symbolic variables they're not supposed
to have values
they just stand for they kind of stand
for something which can stand for
something now these operators
we chose in building axiomatic theory to
just put in these operators
as um uh
you know it's really a plus like thing
but it's not necessarily plus
and so i'm saying the people um okay
and the question the problem is that we
have a proliferation of these things
some of them are unary operators
some of them are things like that's an
identity object
which is kind of an object-like thing
like this and so on
and the problem is we got a whole
proliferation of these things and the
question is what are we going to do with
them
and one possible idea which i want to
float is the possibility of having a
formal operator
that is like a dotted version of plus
where we just go plus
but it is i don't know if i can even do
this on my um
uh boy what is it it would be uh how do
you want control seven
or can control comma are you going above
or below
i want to go below then that's control
comma
yeah that thing which you claim that
nobody ever uses uh
besides the fact that i use it all the
time
i will just point out that you just
wanted it i know
your point is made but
uh shift control comma isn't working
that's it's a little disturbing
let's see below that's what i want oh
control four
you you have an older front end
apparently okay
all right okay so that so then
my question and that doesn't look right
at all but my question would be
one possible approach would be to just
say anything can be dotted
and keeps the same precedence
so i'm saying that's one possibility the
other possibility is that we introduce
a whole bunch of new glyphs basically to
represent all of these
um you know that we we take i'm a little
worried because
we may end up and this is a question for
the axiomatic theory people jonathan
nano others i don't know whether we're
going to end up with
two different plus like operators that
we want to represent
is this making sense to people so it
could definitely happen
well the problem is that what we really
want to do it's very convenient what we
have right now here with circle plus and
so on because
you know if you're trying to type an
expression that involves circle plus
it's very straightforward to do that
etcetera etcetera we have all the
support for it the problem is we need a
boatload of operators
and many of them don't have the right
precedence
see what i'm saying and that's that's
the problem
we can introduce new formal operators
and and
content folk like jonathan can we
can we omanno do we have sort of an
enumeration of what kinds of formal
operators we think we need
not really because i mean what we're
going to be putting into axiomatic
theory is kind of unbounded right now
right i mean so far everything that's in
there is equational
hopefully soon we're going to have first
order logic and then hopefully soon
after that we're going to have you know
higher order logics
but they don't have operators mostly
uh is that true
i don't know you actually i don't really
know i don't think so
and i think most of the infix operator
stuff is equational
look so for example what we've been
doing is we've been using v
as our sort of foe or i mean
whereas if we say or a b at least well
we have
a and then we have backslash bracket or
and that looks kind of the same but v
doesn't evaluate an or does
but i have no idea whether they even
have the same precedence anybody even
know
i think they do but i would i would have
to double check that
well let's let's just intermix them and
we'll find out something at least
um
uh unformatted that's sort of the
easiest way to tell
yeah so i think this is telling us that
v has higher precedence
where is the precedence table tutorial
slash
operator input forms
tutorial singular slash operator and
platforms
yes
a beep to a mysterious off-screen place
okay operator input forms here we go
okay there's wedge
i have no idea where v is
so the issue here i mean again we've got
a certain number of meaningless
operators that we've included in here uh
and you know the challenge is either
just introduce more of them
including uh prefix ones
um could whoever's typing themselves
um or
um or take a different approach
so thoughts from people on this
okay jonathan picking on you okay
what do we think the future i mean so
we've also got even the equality sign
we really need a a a a non-meaningful
equality
sign don't we yes exactly and that you
know that's a
that's a problem we're running into in
these first order theories because the
you know uh almost by definition the
equality predicate is not equational
it's not it's not a predicate of
equation or logic it's an equal it's a
predicate of
first order logic that then defines
equation of logic
um and then and then yeah a bunch of
these right i mean so things like
even subset relations in set theory or
morphism relations in category theory
right
these are all first order or higher
order
kinds of you know kinds of predicates
they're not equational
but we still you know we there are
things like you know
with subset for instance obviously there
are from language symbols for that but
we want to have formal versions of those
which right now we can get we can handle
by putting them in hold
but it would be better if we had a
formal variation okay so that's another
possibility that every one of these
could be done with inactive operators
right whoever's making a background
noise that really
could i mean it was just a whooshing
noise be great if you were a mute
i'm suspicious of john here for some
reason
i'm not hearing anything so maybe i'm to
blame but
then that would be a gas um
okay any case um
okay so look one possibility is an
active orb okay so let's list our
possibilities okay
so one possibility is
um inactivated operators inactivated
ordinary uh ordinary
heads okay another possibility
and and many of those will work i mean
some will format unexpectedly but
i'm pretty sure that inactive of equal
will look
just like he you know right it'll have
the gray styling
of inactive but
oops
uh you need that to be an activate right
and
probably you know add an equal sign or
something
so so one one fundamental problem with
inactive
and is the reason why i didn't want to
use it in axiomatic theory
is because of flatness
inactive preserves flat which they're
improving we don't want
so okay this is a fundamental issue that
we keep running into with these kinds of
things um and it's
whatever our solution to this is i think
it definitely should solve at least this
problem
so um when you do equation or theorem
proving and you define a predicate
that predicate had better have fixed
arity right if you define
an and operator it needs to have fixed
arity the fact that and has
you know has a flat attribute in the
world from language therefore causes
huge problems even if you inactivate it
um right well yes so this doesn't sound
like something that can be solved by
dotting it because i don't know how
i mean but besides even other
implementations
of that it's like how how can't guess
what the new arity is
right okay so fine so so constraints
right so that's an important point is
defined
it doesn't need to get right because i
mean like with circle plus
it doesn't assume linearity does it
well let's find out how horrifying it is
let's find out whether circle plus
abc i think that'll format like that but
now circle plus
of of a b you know a circle plus bc
doesn't doesn't do that because it
doesn't assume associativity it can't
right so so we we can do it with formal
symbols but as
with okay but but neither does and then
if this is your concern right if you do
hold or inactive of and
um right
if you inactivate a nested and it should
be properly nested
that's fair enough yeah okay
okay so what was the thing that that
jonathan was concerned about then maybe
this isn't a problem
um
okay maybe an active is is fine
well so arity is is defined slash fixed
okay so inactivated or ordinary heads
the other will be
dotted operators another would be
new formal operators
now i mean what we have to okay aaron is
defined but what we've got to be
dealing with is both binary operators
binary plus operators
uh we've got probably prefix operators
but sorry just just to quickly finish
the other point i think the thing that
that concerned me the last time we
looked at this
was that if you do something like
inactivate you know
uh um a ampersand amazon b
ampersand m c it assumes that the well
no no no no no no no it doesn't assume
anything
you typed in a flat and right
right if if you touch so inactivate
can't work
inactivate but inactive can i think is
that
no if you type in what you mean
inactivate we'll do it
right do hold complete of
you know a ampersand ampersand b
ampersand ampersand c that parses to a
flat three argument end
right that worked what i just did worked
right because you actually typed in a
nested and
and then because inactivate is hold
first hold all whichever it is it you
know
saw it and it didn't have a chance to
flatten itself via evaluation
and therefore it inactivated what you
wanted
fair enough all right now what happens
if i do traditional form of this
that's terrible why isn't that showing
the nice
um uh you know wedge for the and
because we have no data on
which things uh
you know have alternate right the
we we don't have right when we have like
five different
operators for the same head
you know it it picks one and in this
case it picked that
i mean we could put in a special hack no
no but
but but but i look look
yes and and and and that's because there
is a
special make boxes rule for and
and that um okay but this so this is an
implementation
i mean this is not a point of principle
this is a point of implementation
correct i mean we don't there's no
reason why we think that this
shouldn't work i mean in other words the
traditional form
for you know for plus isn't plus it's a
plus sign
so i'm saying there's no there's no good
reason why this can't work is that
correct
right other than somebody would have to
put in a hack one
operator at a time to get what you want
yes
well i don't know what's a hack i mean
it's just a question what the formatting
of an activated
operator says no i mean there's a
default rule for an active
for an activated operator switch and
that is what the default rule does
if you want to add in a special rule for
but i'm sorry the default
what why isn't the default rule saying
go look at the traditional form that
this would have
if you were not in inactivated because
it i don't think it can do that
why because the
right because we we don't have a table
of that anywhere
okay well fine so we have to create one
okay fine but that's a
let's just i mean this is this is its
own separate little baguette here
which should be fixed but that's that's
separate from our main question
of whether that's even a good idea i
mean this is kind of a killer in terms
of making things look reasonable look
whoever's not on you possibly put
themselves on you thanks
the um uh
let's see um
again the question that we have is
you know in in in setting up these
formal axiom systems
is it obvious that there is a
corresponding ordinary operator
that goes with every operator we're
bringing in here probably not
i mean something you know like group
multiplication
it's kind of like a multiply but do we
really want to consider it actually a
multiply
you know actually at times so to speak
am i making sense
yeah probably not
i mean an activate of of x times y times
z
oh it does have times signs in it that's
nice of it
right because some because lou went in
and added a special rule for times
is is lou here maybe he could kind of
did i am here
and i as i recall etai did this i did
this
okay um
well i guess does it seem obvious to you
how to fix
this case in traditional form
yes yeah i mean
we just add a rule i mean we can do a
one-off for and but there is no no no no
no no i
i why aren't we doing it for everything
everything in traditional
right because how how do you think that
can happen
well to do that we would have to
provisionally typeset it without the
inactive and then
see what it turns into and then somehow
retrofit
right and not every operator will you
not even every binary operator will use
a row box of three things with some
operator in the middle well i mean i'm
sure we can machine generate the code
right because we can i just
run it with that with formal variables
and see what it does
and extract what it does and put that
into a box
and that is the the rule
it's a weird way to do it but that's
what we could do
i don't know what you're suggesting
there well i mean the other possibility
is wherever the traditional form of code
is
there's just a version of it that
basically
would be inserted in the inactive case
no that's not how make boxes roll that's
not how make boxes works
okay okay well then what i'm suggesting
is
you take something like traditional form
of you know take formal a times
b here you know and b okay and you
simply look at
what is the um what is it two boxes
of the traditional form
of a times b given that operator
and you've got the answer there and so
what you do
is you simply go through and for every
operator in this table
you simply ask what is the since you
know
it's binary ternary entry whatever it is
you simply go through and you ask what
is the corresponding boxes form
and that becomes a rule
so you mean hand generates something for
every single
thing it's not hand i mean it's machine
generate but yes
what do you mean machine generate i i i
think what stephen means
is that you machine generate
uh not when the user does it
but we machine generate the rules which
we then
you know uh include with product right
that's what i mean and and some of them
will have to be edited in some careful
way because of the way that inactive
works
okay anyway let's let's let's put that
aside that's a thing that should happen
but that's a different issue
that that's not solving the problem
because what we need here
is formal operators that aren't exactly
plus and times
right and what we've done right now is
we put them you know with circle plus
and so on and what i think we should do
is introduce a certain number
of formal operators that we call formal
this that and the other
um the um
uh with them
um uh what am i saying
with that we can then use now we have to
choose and this is a question
you know when we chose the operator
precedences here you know
years ago 25 years ago whenever it was
more than that now
you know i carefully looked through many
you know
math books and so on and i found to my
great surprise
a huge degree of consistency in
um uh um in the effective precedence
that was being used
am i making sense it's not obvious
that the relative precedence of for all
and you know uh t operations and implies
and so on would be consistent but it was
okay and that's what the and there
really wasn't a lot of ambiguity i mean
it was really very slam dunk
and that's what this that's what led to
this precedence table
okay but so now the question is can we
introduce a
new collection of i don't know 20 30 uh
you know
formal operators whose precedences
are fairly uncontroversial that can be
used to
form these formal uh
you know axiomatic theory setups so
that question makes sense to people
sounds good to me all right i mean if
we're just talking about adding a
fixed number of operators with you know
in the standard manner then i see no
problem
with with doing that right other than
you know i guess
andre will need to chase after
well i guess if we if we're okay with
programmatically adding the dot to the
existing glyph
no no we're not we're not because i
don't think that works
you know because we can end up with two
formal plus operators right
you understand what i'm saying so that's
not going to work right so we're going
to have to come up with
what by by which you mean a prefix
version and an infix version no worse
than that
you think of arithmetic you know okay
look at this case this is the accidents
of ring theory
okay ring theory one of the models of
ring theory
is traditional arithmetic with plus and
times
um i'm not educated enough to know maybe
jonathan could tell us what the other
models of ring theory are
i'm sure there are other models there
are dozens right
i mean yes okay there are many yes
obviously right okay
i'm being silly here anyway so but the
the ordinary plus
that we we say plus plus78
okay isn't that plus this is the formal
plus of which that is just one model
and the thing which is awkward is there
could be an axiomatic system
where there are two things that behave a
bit like plus
um but aren't really plus if you
understand what i'm saying john does
that make sense
right yeah and that's why but this is
where we have to
you know what we did in version three
was we guessed
you know we we introduced all of these
operators without built-in meanings
which frankly have not been much used
over the years
you know people we've got all these
lovely operators like you know that the
union this this thing here and so on but
people don't use them
now finally we actually have a use for
them and in axiomatic theory we have
been making use of things like circle
plus
and circle times and they've been very
helpful so
you know it could be that the right
solution here which involves a subset of
people here
is that we simply go to the idea that we
will have
essentially formal operators with
certain names
that are just glyphs and they just act
accordingly
okay and and um you know they are an
extension of our
operators without built-in values type
stuff
that makes sense i mean that's what
we're doing but the problem is that for
example we don't have an adequate
collection of prefix operators
the only one that is really common is
the square and
you know i've used that a lot but it's
just like a really weird thing that you
you know
yeah we don't have we don't have a lot
of prefix operators period
but uh but yes uh the ones without
built-in meaning
are even more rare um right but now we
also have
you know we also have what we might call
overfix operators
um and i don't know whether those are
important i mean i've certainly used
those
in um uh you know i've used this
in um in the axiomatic theory stuff in
fact i think we use that for not
don't we in um uh do we use that in
boolean algebra
yes okay so that's a that's kind of a
hack because it's a
it's a unary operator that sort of looks
like a um
a negation and um uh so we're using it
for that it's a
unary operator without built-in meaning
there's also
there's the corner case that you can see
in the ring axioms
stuff um that okay so
one of the one of the design decisions
we made with axiomatic theory
was to treat constants as effectively
operators of arity zero
yes right so like uh you know you can
see the the
the additive and multiplicative
constants there are treated as just
those are treated as as operators and
presumably those would be formalized
and we used in that case we use over
tildes to make them into
you know to distinguish them from actual
zeros and ones
yeah now for example nick on the live
stream is commenting that the function
he wrote find headaches
well that got all tangled up with an
active symbols it will similarly get
tangled up with these kinds of things
gets tangled up with inactive symbols as
well they're a bit of a nightmare
well okay so with these nullery
operators
or what do we call them they're not
they're not unity operators they're
they're zero area operators what is a
zero
a operator called i don't know anyway
that th there is the possibility that we
could just introduce new symbols to
represent those zero array operators
a formal you know so that would be
something like formal one
formal zero right right
um which would then just be you know
symbols like this
and and those to be consistent could
potentially be
i mean i'm not sure this is the right
right strategy but they could be
dotted versions or something of um
of normal things
um so i mean this is the question really
is is can we consistently invent okay so
what we're coming down to here
is that what we need are just a bunch of
new glyphs is that well
okay i mean did i hear correctly that
just putting a dot alone isn't going to
be enough because you need variances
and so these are i think so more than
just dotted
things they'll have some other well i
know i mean i'm hearing that
maybe a dot would be sufficient in some
cases but not in every case
well it's also we need a style well like
just to be clear you're not suggesting
that we have more than one formal plus
just because there
there are more models of plus than
one no no i'm saying that there are
theories in which
there are two plus-like operators i
think well okay
let me let me give a trivial example if
we if we wanted to axiomatize module
theory for instance or you know the
axioms of vector spaces
you have the plus of the field of
scalars and you have the plus of the
vectors and those are different
operations
right field the ring of scalars or
whatever
so the question yeah go ahead i mean the
the way i see it is
ultimately okay so if does somebody have
an example
maybe we can pull up an example from
find equational proof of of
um one of those you know syllogism type
things because that's a
that's an axiomatization where all bets
are off in terms of
of using infix operators and so on
you you mean a first order syllogism yes
for example is that in here yeah there's
there's one of the yeah the socrates one
at the bottom there yeah okay
so this you know we're not going to have
mortality is not um
uh you know it's never going to be an
infix operator we're not going to want
that
within fixed operators no but we
well i mean okay for instance might we
want things like betweenness
in euclidean geometry yes we might so
let me give an example then of where
we're going with this let me show you an
example
where i had did you know wrote out
accidentization of all the axiom systems
that i
sort of knew at the time right um your
your typical interpretations
section of that uh where where it is
page 774
has you know basically i think most of
the operators that we would want to
include
oh my gosh brady did this actually
expand correctly
well yeah that's been live yay well done
good work great example of you
this was a great use case for that you
the
um right so here we go
right but can can i get back to the plus
thing
so right so i agree that axiomatize
vector spaces or modules you nee
you need the you need the the the field
or or ring plus and you need the vector
module plus which typically when you're
doing that
then you'll use plus for the field
and circle plus for the vector space or
some such
exactly obviously there are generalized
cases where we you know
the more varia in my view the more
variants we have the better
but i mean so this is a typical thing in
you know
mathematical logic you know in the end i
mean okay the good news is in the end we
can go to things like this in the end we
can just go
to random symbols but
to make these axiom systems look nice we
might as well have as much
diversity as we can it seems to me
knowing that there's a fallback
and the fallback is not going to tangle
up any theorem prover it's not going to
tangle up anything because it is in fact
the same structural arity type form
that the original was supposed to be
it's just it doesn't have an infix
format
does that does that make sense to people
so i mean things like empty set we
probably want a formal
empty set that might be different from
some future you know empty set
that is i mean i i'm surprised we've
never needed an empty set symbol oh we
have an
empty we have an empty set character we
certainly do
i don't think it means anything uh
i don't think that the empty cell i
don't think if i say i think it's a
letter like form
yeah it's a letter like form so it
creates a symbol in the current context
right which could in fact be the empty
set symbol if we wanted it to be
if if you know since we don't have a
notion of sets really
we don't you know we haven't needed that
um
uh ethan is giving us a list
of um of symbols that could be added
let's take a look here
um oh boy this is uh yeah i mean look
ultimately we can add any unicode
character and i think we can
have i mean that's another question okay
so next question is can we
preempt unicode
can can we give a formal meaning
i.e parsing for a random unicode
character
no you're saying we shouldn't
i'm saying we shouldn't
so you think anything that we put in
here should be in private unicode space
well there are or it should correspond
to
the if right if if the
same if that operation exists as a
character in unicode then we could reuse
that
yeah i mean there may be ranges of
unicode glyphs that have
you know are intended to have the kind
of semantic meaning we want to ascribe
to it and in which case it'd be fine
okay so so let's assess that i mean
maybe maybe maybe unicode already has
some nice section for mathematical logic
where it already has all these things it
has several
sections on mathematical notation i
think no no mathematical logic i said
because this is where this is going to
come up well yes but mathematical
notation
includes is is broadly defined
so i mean there are sections which are
literally called mathematical
operators or mathematics i know i know i
know i know so so ethan sent us this
thing on the live stream so let's
let's just look at well that's tech
i'm aware but i'm asking whether it even
has a section
for logic okay
oh my gosh it's got fragrance but
mcgregor schriften
symbols in it wow
i'm impressed that is definitely on the
obscure end of things
did don knuth really talk about those
anywhere in his books
uh note that's not that's not in latex
itself that's a package that's a that's
a package called fraga
oh oh i see
okay i mean that even if it's obscure
enough to have the progress shift
supported by default
but but so these so let's take a look at
unicode then
um okay so this really doesn't have a
lot of other logic
maybe it does i don't know um
nothing obvious now i mean it has
it has at least some logic symbols you
know it has the
you have the implications you have if
and only if
uh what else do you have how do we find
a unicode character
um i'm i'm looking at a wikipedia page
called mathematical operators and
symbols in unicode
adopt a character i didn't know they had
that
i'm anxiously poised to receive your
command to add homer simpson to her
characters what is this this is really
weird
that is bizarre
huh i had no idea this was possible
that's interesting and strange
um that is a new thing that's that's
something i'm
surprised is um uh okay i put a link in
chat that may or may not be relevant
it's
slightly older not homer simpson it's
not homer simpson it's unicode
oh darn
okay operators
so are you saying i mean wait a minute
and and jonathan have put
a um i i have a better link now so
if you oh sorry not that if you look at
this wikipedia page
every one of the symbols on this page
has a unicode version if there is a
unicode
value
that's not a lot of operators not a lot
of things
well it is if you include the advanced
ones where are the advanced ones
advanced and rarely used symbols
so you know they have nand nor reversed
turn style
complements unique existence
i have a bad feeling that we invented
that symbol for nand
or am i wrong i think we did
um is your hatred of the chef a stroke
showing through well i think it should
be dot
in in interesting cases yeah the chef
chef of stroke is really obscure
um this is not a huge list if i might
say so
what what mathematical logic symbols do
you think are missing from this
well mathematical logic as such fine
but things that are formal you know
formal versions of operators useful for
mathematical theories represented in
mathematical logic terms
plenty is missing by the way i do think
the true and false symbols are useful
here
i agree and those are just but we see
look at this this is oh i see this is
backslash top
in which one do we give uh do we give
the
eighteen six eight okay
backslash bracket eight eight six i mean
whatever it
that is not what i thought it was going
to be oh
it we give the 2 to a 4 what do we give
john you get the u plus one don't you
john what do we give him backslash colon
uh uh
four digit hex hex yeah
okay all right so this is now
okay whatever the thing is let's see
that's probably a t
i mean if you unformat it you'll see
that it
it's not just that all right if you just
unformat it you'll see it will have
transformed itself
to backslash bracket down t if you
unformat
that uppers at that input cell okay
all right fine but but that means that
down t
now does down t have pausing rules
of course it does
yeah i mean
well so that's the end of that as as
meaning tautology
right in fact this is wrong i mean what
they've done here
this is incorrect i mean this should be
semantically tautology
but in fact what they're doing is
they're trying to hijack the down t
symbol and claim that it's tautology
which is wrong
so i'm distinctly unconvinced by this
list okay so i think that makes the case
right but
if yeah so uh here actually let me give
you
a better link so this is the the actual
table
of uh unicode operators
so it's the table of contents and then
you'll not find that there are
uh you know various sections there's
methyl
operators supplemental mathematical
operators
um and i think we've probably
implemented a bunch of these
but whereas
mathematical
mathematical symbols okay letter like
symbols
mathematical operators okay so
supplemental
operators
yeah i don't know how useful these are
because the problem is for mathematical
representations of theories we need
multiple times like operators
and having something some bizarre
creature that looks like this doesn't
really help with that
i mean we could arbitrarily start using
bow ties
but that seems pretty random
um
yeah i mean to me i think we're gonna
have to draw some new glyphs because i
don't think these glyphs these are not
useful i mean these are
these are fine and dandy but they're not
what already
yeah it's well it's also not the
complete list but yes i mean we mirror
well it's not the complete list of
i mean like like the fact that they've
got a double circle times
there well this isn't the complete list
of all the operators right this is one
section
um but uh but wait a minute
where where do i go for the rest of them
i've got
well miscellaneous
mathematical symbols probably
um at least i think there are more i
could be wrong
but uh
there there's a large group of
mathematical uh alphanumerics
uh but uh the
you know the sections we're looking in
right now is where
the majority of the operators are
right but but mathematism the
miscellaneous mathematical symbols does
have a fair number
of operators like and with dot
so if you want end with dot uh
there's a unicode point for that um
okay let me make a claim yeah okay
i have a feeling that most of these
unicode characters had an intended use
and it's not our intended use
and therefore we probably shouldn't use
them for that because eventually
that might i mean who knows what one of
these things is but there may be some
field in which that's
a thing well i'm not suggesting
using arbitrary things i'm suggesting
using things that look like the
operators we want
like there's an and with dot i i
understand that i understand that but i
think that we're going to have a whole
family of things
to which we give parsing rules and what
worries me
is like for example let's take this
example of down t
okay it probably seemed like the right
thing at the time to make down
t be an infix operator okay
but the truth is that page claimed that
down t is
is the is the true symbol tautology
right which is a
uh you know well then well that i think
that's just
wrong well okay fair enough but i mean
that's the point that
you know in the in the world of adopt a
symbol
right the question is are these things
you know
through and through meaning whatever
they mean
or are they i mean this this is a very
weird how to think about this
so the issue is you've got these glyphs
i mean it's like the fact that okay the
question is
if there was a chinese character that
happened to look like a z
would people entrain the ascii z
to be that chinese character answer
probably not
but i think there are places where i
mean in a sense that's what's happening
you know okay back in the day when there
used to be these iso
you know iso latin four character set
and so on
those kinds of things there was another
a
in isolatin four that was different from
the a that we use
in ascii that makes sense to people
yeah and they still exist in unicode
yeah and
and you know i mean there's there's all
kinds of things like this you know
there's there's the
half with uh katakana characters there's
uh
uh greek capitals that just happen to
look
very very much like roman capitals
um right right i mean look it goes into
you know back when i used to use a
typewriter it didn't have a one key on
it because you used a lowercase
l to represent a one right
so i mean this has been going for a long
time but the question is do we want to
buy into that idea
i had forgotten that but i think that we
had such a
typewriter yeah well that's the way they
worked
i don't think any typewriters had ones
on them i think it was viewed as a
superfluous
glyph okay in any case the um
but uh uh you know
my tendency is to say unless the
description here
right i i agree did the description in
order to reuse an existing code point we
have to
have the description must match our
intended use
okay however the problem is that like
the old
i mean you know like typesetters back in
the day when there were human type
setters with lead type and so on
right they always had names for
uh mathematical characters and they were
kind of humorously direct
okay there were things like fences for
example those are
those are the absolute value signs we're
called fences
um i don't remember any of the others
but they were kind of fun because they
were really just
purely this is what it looks like no
no reference to the meaning and i think
that's what unicode
you know pretty much picked up
if i'm making sense rather than so much
giving meanings to these things because
here
we've got you know left s-shaped bag
delimiter
okay then we've got open subset this is
a mess guys
this is a mess i mean oh boy
see look at this white triangle
containing small white triangle and then
we've got three dimensional angle
so three dimensional angle is a semantic
statement of what it's supposed to mean
and then some of these others you know
upper left corner with dot
it's just a structural description
that makes sense i mean look left
multi-map
is totally different from left and right
double turn style
turn style last i knew it is not a
mathematical concept
is this making sense
um right although there is there is a
right these
this is sort of the short form there's
usually
more information somewhere about you
know sort of the intended semantic
meaning
although right for a lot of these are
they're sort of random
right they don't have they're sort of
random things that are used
for in different situations and for
different things but
that's in the category of use though use
the l key on the typewriter for a one
right so the question is so what unicode
i think has done
is likely use the l key for a one it's
like the glyph looks roughly right use
it for that
right so i mean here it gives them look
square logical
and says morphological min product
operator additive minimum operator
so these are possible meanings that's
the same thing we did
in and who knows maybe they got this for
our side i remember we were working
interacting with them a bunch in those
days um
the um
um
yeah there are a number of interesting
questions here on the on the uh on the
live stream let me just look at some of
these
um there's ethan is commenting that our
symbols palette is utterly old
and needs a search field in it and i
agree with that and that should be
listed as a project for somebody um
possibly that's a small noah project
brady that's for you to to make a note
of this
you could add that to user assistance
okay
um then uh
nick is commenting there's a difference
between arity zero and no arity
yes you're absolutely right i mean arity
zero
would be the i mean by nullery i didn't
mean
okay so then there's yes i mean how to
say this i mean arity 0
what is the right term for this arity 0
operators
means something of the form f open close
whereas what is the right term for this
this thing where it isn't an operator at
all it has
it is you know that's the way that we
are handling
these formal you know constants
right but look in logic they're just
called constants but the point is
axiomatic theory treats them as though
they're arity zero
operators like if you call you know
axioms operators it will show the
identity as being an arity zero operator
right um
okay emergence ets i'm going to call
them
on them on our live stream is asking
can you make custom symbols like draw an
operator yourself
no because we don't have a good way to
define precedence
um that was a i've told the story 700
times in
smp we had a way for people to define
operative residences
what a disaster that was um i
you know it's some uh
i mean i yeah i don't think actually
actually you kind of can
uh because uh you know
if if you're willing to do uh you know
work at the box level because you can
uh wrap your thing in a tag box and use
a syntax form option to make it work
like an existing uh operator
uh so if you're happy to
you know have it be equivalent to the
existing operator for purposes of
associativity and precedence and such
then the answer is yes
isn't there a way of i mean there are
precedence values numerical precedence
values can't you set those
with precedence form well so
i mean the thing is you need something
that
works like an operator and you know the
the
the tag box with the syntax form option
can encompass anything and make it work
like an operator
i see it it looks like a plus and it
talks like a plus but it doesn't look
like a problem
but syntax form is just limited in that
you can't give syntax form
a raw precedence and associativity and
such you have to specify it in terms of
an existing operator
okay i i actually uh posted an example
of that
in the chat right at the beginning
before the conversation
went someplace else and
and actually precedence form is the
opposite it
tells you for output formatting
parenthesize this thing as if it had
this precedence
so i i i began to understand that this
example doesn't represent that this
doesn't represent
the direction we probably want to go but
maybe for
the purpose of answering the question
you can see so what can i do here
well so like you know if you copy and
paste these guys
into you know like a formal plus b
formal times c formal times d and you'll
see
you know then the selection um
um you know works
equivalently but it doesn't yeah you're
gonna have to write uh make expression
rule for it but if you like you know
triple click one of these things or
something like that
it you know it's mimicking the operator
it's based on
right what do we think
even so far as if you do you know formal
star b formal star c
you know you get something flat uh you
know
right that by the way
is why monospace fonts are awesome for
coding
well you can tell the difference between
those guys yes
because otherwise i'm sure if we did
text of that
yeah um
okay okay so so
backing up here by the way hans asks how
much space is left
in our created fonts to add our own
glyphs oh lots
and there's a lot of space in private
unicode yeah so
um you know we still have a decent
amount in plane zero
private unit code and soon we'll
have full support of you know beyond
plane zero and there's there's a
ton of space and how bad is it when we
use private unicode
what do we do when we copy paste into
into some other application
we use long names
i see so then what would happen we
always convert anything
uh you know unless you're copying a
bitmap of it of course
um you know but we'll always use a long
name
uh because we don't we don't seriously
expect anyone else to understand
you know our private unicode that's not
a reasonable expectation
so if i take this and i paste it into
you know a piece of email or something i
will get
oh boy i get all kinds of
i see well i mean that's right but but
if your recipient then takes
right but if if if your recipient
then takes this and pastes it back into
their notebook it'll
regenerate but even if i just take that
small piece
the the a b piece there that's still
kind of
kind of breakfast you know well that's
not too bad that's just no
no that'll be quite reasonable but it
isn't
okay fine so we've already crossed that
bridge basically so what anything we do
in private unicode space not gonna be
any worse for this
right okay so i think the conclusion is
um
um i think the conclusion is we should
make our own glyphs
and that we should pick the precedences
that basically what we're going to do
is you know the same thing we've always
done which is just like
in the main design of orphan language
we're picking functions that will seem
useful
we're going to pick you know glyphs and
precedences and so on that will seem
useful
for purposes of of um um
you know for these formal theory
purposes so now that that
really just degenerates into i mean by
the way is there any problem
technically with these nullery operators
they're just symbols like like that
they'll presumably be letter like forms
just like exactly that
yes the the kernel on the front end will
both just read them as letter-like forms
and that will not be an issue okay right
we'll just need to
when they're added we'll just need to
make sure they're created in system and
protected so that they remain as true
you know is there any problem we've
already got some ternary operators right
tilde is already a ternary operator so
we can presumably do the um
uh in the few cases like the between
operator
which is ternary we can deal with that
right
um so the uh
um i mean you can potentially do
quite exotic things with ternary and you
may not
understand what's exotic from a parsing
perspective um
yes we have some basic ternary stuff and
it's
you know we uh uh like like the tilde
example
uh the front end actually doesn't
understand it properly as ternary
uh and we kind of hack around that and
make expression
um so you know a tilde b
tilde c tilde d the front end just
considers that
flat because the front end doesn't
really understand ternariness
okay all right but make expression does
right and so and so that will fail to
parse
unless you add some parentheses
somewhere to tell make expression what
you mean
okay i understand so you're saying a
tilde b tilde c tilde to a tilde c will
work just fine
but then this if i add a tilde d
it'll okay well that's fine but but then
until the e
will parse
but if you look at what the front end
did if you show so
that is very bizarre that it parses with
that right associativity
yeah but but but if but the front end
didn't do anything clever here
the front end just treated tilde as a
flat operator and
make expression figured out what you're
looking at
okay fine all right so look i think this
this discussion has devolved into
we need to actually do the mathematical
okay so now now the only question is is
there a style that we want to get
um the uh
oh yeah i'm just going to comment on
sandra on the live stream comments
that when we when you paste a greek
letter
like eta that that pastes as backslash
bracket eta
the reason for that is that we're not
using raw greek characters
and in fact i just got burnt with this
because i was just doing something which
you'll see in a
couple of days of about euclid where i'm
quoting euclid in greek
and there are greek characters that have
accents on them but they are we have
automatically translated into our
mathematical greek font which is italic
maybe andre wants to comment on this
actually actually i have a comment about
this
uh which is that uh right now
we are using uh
the uh you know the unicode code points
for
standard greek letters except for
epsilon
which you know there was a mathematical
epsilon that's you know in unicode plane
zero
but this is you know i mean this is you
know
was probably the best decision you know
in 1996 but there are better things we
can do now
because uh we created kind of a a mess
for
our greek users unfortunately and we've
tried you know
various ways to you know make it better
wait wait wait these are these are users
who would otherwise have been using iso
greek
the iso greek encoding before unicode
yes correct
yes and they won't have any problem with
the iso greek encoding but now that
they're merged it's a big mess
so you know i mean there's a question of
well do you want to use a greek
character from just whatever font you
were using that's greek
um or do you want our mathematical
greeks
which are you know have a special sort
of styling which
as you say for example they they have an
italicized sort of appearance
you know that's part of our calling out
this is a mathematical thing
well since you know since we first did
this
um you know there's a range of
mathematical greeks that's now come into
existence
uh and it's on our roadmap
to uh switch over our long names
for you know alpha beta gamma so on uh
to instead of pointing to standard greek
to point to these mathematical greeks
uh and that will be a compatible change
because our notebooks contain long names
right
exactly yes we we would uh
uh you know there you could
find sources of incompatibility but but
99 of what people ever do will just work
unless you're agreed unless you're greek
what's that
uh so that's greek right that's the
greek iso greek
mapping correct yeah correct
and and and and this would instead
become um
um yeah i don't know the value but it's
not in plain zero
you know it's it would be uh uh you know
a hundred thousand something now we
yeah well
i mean as the capabilities go that's
probably not the most devastating one i
mean conceivably
the the greek character you get
when you're in text could be from
a base font that is not ours right well
well
this is so this is the dance that we do
for our greek users
i mean we detect you know is your
preferred language
your or your preferred operating system
language greek and
if so then we do
different things for them um and
uh and i want to get to a world where we
can stop doing that
um because i mean you know for for those
of us who aren't greek you know it's
like maybe we're quite happy
i don't have greek friends but uh
but it is painful for our greek users
and we need to deal with that
well and to support it properly we're
talking about expanding our font
um to have the a non-italic looking
greek characters
right no no no no no i'm sorry we're
just going to use the
the standard fonts system fonts yes
because the whole point is saying is
that there are now mathematical greek
characters
in standard system fonts the i
i mean what you know what we want is
look you know
there isn't just one font for greek
right
for for narrative you know modern greek
you know there's
there's a bunch of fonts and you know
people don't want to
we're saying we're saying the font
originally designed by andre that is our
mathematical font
we could still perfectly well use for
the hundred thousand
whatever absolutely no unicode
absolutely we we just
yes we just need to you know uh
move some uh you know move some glyphs
around um
you know you know change their mappings
slightly but right uh
you know that's a trivial thing right
okay so so just going back to this
um the um
uh let's see but
i i just want to talk about one last
thing here we're not going to get
everything straightened out here but i
think we've got a road map which
involves a much smaller number of people
here um
the um um
[Music]
which is what is our style for
a formal character so we have chosen
to use these dots for formal
symbols which i am not a huge fan of if
if i wanted to make those formal symbols
be a different color
or slightly different color is that
doable technically or not
the dot itself is gray it is yeah yeah
the dot itself
is is not uh it's a
it's not gray it's it's slightly
transparent
so the so the color follows the coloring
of
you know the i mean i guess this is in
the land of emoji we are the
beneficiaries of emoji somehow yeah
a true statement that the characters can
be
so what you're saying is if we wanted to
get rid of the dots
and make these just a slightly different
color we could do that
so well i mean but
i wouldn't i like that the dots
work they they they're more noticeably
meaningful
changing color won't be as noticeably
meaningful and we've used so many
software's already in our code and the
principle
and the principle question is what do
you want font color to do on these
things
font color on a color emoji can't do a
thing
um so i understand but so you're saying
here
that dot because it is purely um
uh opacity if i say style of this
comma purple exactly
this will i see beautiful
right okay like that right and if you i
suppose if you made it pink
if you made it pink and added a uh
black background then the dot would be
slightly darker than that that's correct
that is absolutely correct yes right so
in fact here i see what you're saying so
if i
if i say white here and i say background
arrow gray
this will if i could only see it
be magnificent right good okay
okay so so fine so we're we're staying
dotty
um so the question is uh
[Music]
what do we do with these operators what
is our style for a formal operator
do we go dotty for that as well
or do we have some other way of
indicating that something is formal
and i need to go to another meeting in a
second um
that's my i'm prepared to say dot but i
guess i could see
have if there's a dot under everything
maybe
it becomes less clear i don't know what
would it look like
let me see because john has a has a
dotting machine here
so we can probably it's it's not perfect
because it's
not lined up correctly but uh yeah
you get the idea though but what do you
think graphically
if um question andre jeremy et cetera i
mean honestly i don't think this would
look so
awful if everything was dotted here it
might even look better
than only some things being dotted well
i don't know i mean that was my point
that the some things being dotted make
those some things stand out
and maybe that's useful it's a visual
interruption
particularly useful it's interruptive
okay
um but yeah i i lean towards sticking
with this
under dot approach i i was quite happy
with it as we
settled on it because remember we used
to do over and under and that was too
noisy
yes but so maybe what we want to do here
then
is i mean and then what it'll look like
if everything is dotted
it'll almost look like a you know
partial underline type thing which i
think is sort of okay
and then my suggestion for the formal
operators would be
that we use times and plus as
circles we use a circled version um
and then for the extra you know we have
a double circle
version and and maybe what we call them
is
formal circle time i don't know we call
them formal times formal
what do we call them if we have two
formal you know we call them formal
circle plus
that's at least clear but then we call
it formal
formal double circle plus or something
jonathan or anybody else you've got
comments on this
so the i mean the the latex convention
is to have like you know a letter and
then and then variations of the letter
are preceded by
var so like you have epsilon you have
one i know that yeah but
but i mean it would be consider so what
you just
suggested stephen is consistent with our
naming convention so
that would be formal circle plus and
formal
double circle plus i mean just like we
have double integral sign
and um
well it's fine but then then so it's a
little bit verbose you know if you have
to type that in
it's pretty painfully verbose
but if you just need to do escape you
know
d e d c f plus or
i i guess f or the dollar whatever it is
right so that's c plus instead of circle
plus right so we'd need
c plus i guess dollar is is what we are
using
of trailing dollar for formal variables
i think
i think escape a dollar i think is
formal a
so i think we could just do that yeah so
bob is commenting on our livestream
bob had mentioned earlier something
about do we have
vertex algebras vertex operator algebras
i don't know what those are
no what are they they're uh
they're they're they're a type of
operator algebra defined
over the complexes that uh are useful in
string theory
and other uh sorts of algebraic geometry
things are there are they just a formal
system or i mean do they have axioms
yes although usually they you know you
you you think about sort of specific you
know concrete ones that arise in
practice although i'm sure i'm sure the
mathematicians will treat them
completely abstractly in
in the physics world you're more
typically concerned with the concrete
ones that appear
in in string theory so that
there is a fully accidentized version of
vertex operator algebras but they
require having concepts like vector
spaces and you know linear
multiplications and endomorphisms and
things
that we currently don't have right in
principle it's perfectly possible to do
okay so so what we think we're doing
here is most
of um you know we'll have a formal equal
i don't think we'll have a formal for
all
because some uh
um
the um uh because for all it's actually
a meaningful concept
in our logical theories we need to have
a separate meeting about forall
because if we want to support higher
order logic in you know the next version
we need to modify how for all works
okay okay let's get that meeting
i know and that'll obviously need to
include people like adam and roger
can you say jonathan what the change
that you need is
yes so if you try uh if you say you know
for all
f x y and then you say you know f of x y
equals f of y x
what the heck is that for fx what what
the heck is that i'm very confused what
does
what i must have said some yeah i think
these you'd attach some definition to
for all that is
triggering
[Music]
huh or for all is broken
i don't know that's obviously correct
because the because oh because there's
no
appearance of the x there but i'm saying
if you quantify all the f x and y
and then you say f of x y equals f of y
x or something
well but this partic this thing here
does not quantify over the f and you're
saying it needs to
for a second so in order
in order to support higher order logics
we need to be able to quantify the
predicates so right now my higher order
logic theorem improver
gets around that by putting everything
by putting for all in hold
form um but if this doesn't look too
too horrifying i don't see an obvious
problem with this unless
except that clearly we can do things
like saying things like
um you know for all square root like
this
which might get a little bit weird right
boy there's a question from bob can
variables be double
formal no i don't think so i think that
they i mean this is a complicated mess
right this is the what is a variable is
a very complicated story
i mean these are
this this quickly segues into the
general story of naming which is one of
the
sort of banes of many many things
um all right but i think
i think the convention we're going to
use then is that we're going to use
pretty plain operators but we're going
to dot them
and that means that in our meeting to
talk about
operators we basically are just going
foraging and unicode
for operators and they could be unicode
operators that mean anything
and we're just going to have a we're
going to build our own glyph
that basically has that form dotted and
we're going to call it formal whatever
we choose to call it
so if we're going to use the standard
uh uh you know visual
visuals that we have for dotting that
means then that the implementation
is is back in the front end camp um
there
won't be anything for andre to do if all
the symbols
no but we're going to have to have
precedent no andre won't have anything
to do but there will have to be
precedence set up for all of them
oh no no no i'm not i'm not saying that
wouldn't be the case i'm just saying
that the uh
uh the rendering of the glyph will be uh
composed by the front end as opposed to
uh
uh or synthesized by the front end i
suppose so what you're gonna need
basically what what what it's probably
going to be mano who ends up actually
delivering this stuff
is this table there's presumably a
version of this table has actual
precedence numbers in it
we we we actually have
a procedure for
submitting characters and it includes
all the information that you need
uh and um i can
um it's it's just a twiki that people
can you know drop stuff into
okay fine fine okay so can you provide
that
to um to jonathan sorry i guess to
jonathan and jose sure yeah
am i the okay um
and uh okay fine then we'll need a
separate meeting that is a glyph
selection meeting um
go ahead yeah i just was speaking of
character requests
uh uh are you okay
with uh app as the
[Music]
input alias for application
uh do we have a do we have a glyph for
application now
we do not we and we don't have the
character
because we need all the information
uh so last time we were talking about
using
this right half filled circle
uh yeah i wasn't completely completely
sold on that
yes that was we were close on that i
think does anybody has anybody started
designing that glyph
i mean no um
and so i guess and
i i personally would prefer ap than app
okay i don't see any reason to have an
extra character there i don't think it
does any particular good
um i mean you can support both of them
if you want to but
i would say ap is is what we should have
and um i think the the the half-filled
circle is a little bit fussy
i mean i i'd like to see how it comes
out i mean it could be that a circle
just with a bit of
waiting on one side will be okay
or even just flattening on one side
might be okay what about a circle with
flattening i mean i just think
it's really really fussy to have
something that looks like
you know a moon phase character or
something
yeah but you're back to the situation we
once had in the past where you
recommended a dot being slightly ovoid
as if
anybody could possibly tell the
difference you know
uh it's just i i don't know
i think that it that minimal amount of
distortion could be perceived as
anti-aliasing failure or you know
something
that just isn't yes okay so this is a
glyph design question i mean
i mean let's try some out i mean
basically what we've agreed is it's a
circle
with some kind of weighting on one side
of it how that waiting works
is up to the gulf designer all right
i'll i'll i'll put that in the ticket i
guess for andy h
andre uh uh yeah that's a good starting
point i mean he'll run it by
others of us but yeah okay and
and and we'll get that but yes uh so
we should have the the code point in in
the next few days and then it'll just be
waiting for a glyph
great great excellent did we do we know
the precedence
did we figure that out we did didn't we
yes i forget
exactly where i think we put it between
at and
yeah we we figured this out yes um
okay okay sounds good
all right thanks guys thanks for the
comments on the live stream too
alright see y'all soon the